I had written nearly 3,000 words that
day and in the afterglow of
self-satisfaction I decided that there
was certainly something in this life of
rural seclusion after all in Bloomsbury
far too many people were acquainted with
me and my address
they were just dropping in on me at all
hours of the night and day with complete
disregard for my work in their
assumption a writer was a person who
never worked anyway his stories were
things he just dashed off in odd moments
now and again with no particular thought
as one dashes off letters after a string
of nights on short rations of sleep
trying to recover some of the time the
stolen for me during the day I dashed
off myself away from London and these
vampires of my attention my friends I
took care that none of them none but
Spencer that is should know my address
until I was good and ready for them and
that meant when I had finished my novel
it was safe to tell Spencer he never saw
any of my other friends they avoided him
because he was odd eccentric in his
musty bed sitting-room in Mecklenburg
square he lived in a world of his own
you sense the strangeness as soon as you
stepped into the room and it was
certainly enhanced by his presence he
was faddish why I don't know for I never
saw him eat anything and I believe older
than he looked he looked in his early
60s trying to maintain a conversation
with him was indeed trying you felt that
quite two-thirds of his attention was
somewhere else all the time and he only
intermittently remembered that you were
there and most of what he said to you he
deliberately made cryptic he had a
tortuous mind that loved to puzzle and
mystify many times I had remonstrated
with him for God's sake Spencer speaks
straightforwardly and sensibly will you
I can make more sense out of my income
tax correspondence than I can out of you
when he did make sense out of him it was
invariably worth the trouble
he had more odd knowledge tucked away
inside his head than Ripley ever dreamed
upon and he was full of surprising
little tidbits that made me exclaim that
gives me an idea for a story
I made quite a lot of money out of
Spencer in this way maybe that was why I
looked upon him as my best friend in
fact the main reason that I elected to
keep in touch with him from my lonely
cottage among the gorse and pines of
Surrey was because my novel dealt with
medieval witchcraft and I anticipated
difficulty over one or two chapters I
might need to dig in dispensers fund of
knowledge about such things also he had
the best library of books on the occult
that I had ever come across it was
through a previous search for
out-of-the-way information that I
originally encountered him but about
that evening when I was wandering alone
across the Surrey Heath so comfortably
satisfied with the day's work it was an
evening in midsummer when the atmosphere
was closed and still and the going of
the Sun had seemed to leave it more warm
and oppressive than noonday the air was
a thick almost liquid substance from
which your lungs were hard-pressed to
draw oxygen almost as thick as the blood
which pumped at your temples and made
your head throb heavily headachy weather
and you longed for a storm to come and
break it up somewhere this night there
was a storm for along the horizon the
sheet lightning flickered and jumped and
revealed silently weird little imps 'as
of an unsuspected cloud land that lay
out there in the darkness
I don't know whether it's peculiar to me
but these strange tense evenings of
summer always set my imagination working
more actively than the chilly autumn and
winter nights beloved of the Gothica
Romantic poets Keats would begin in a
drear night of December and pose you
lalume would be carried to her tomb in
the ghoul Haunted woodland of we're on a
night in the lonesome October and as for
the same gentleman's Raven who quotes
Nevermore odd distinctly I remember it
was in the Bleak December no the winter
was merely physically uncomfortable a
hot thundery night like this made me
mentally uncomfortable uneasily I sensed
the imminence of something I felt the
electric charge slowly but unrelentingly
building itself up in the air about me
forming something unknown but black and
inimical growing both in power and in
consciousness of its power awaiting with
evil excitement the hour of its
unleashing damnit I thought I've been
thinking too much upon these things this
was the last novel I would write about
the occult
the trouble with such an occupation was
that the story becomes real to you as
you write it and you are disposed to
picture warlocks and werewolves as
things you might find in a dark corner
of the coal cellar at some unlucky
moment especially when you have
deliberately retired to solitude to get
into your book the glow of my
self-esteem had now died somewhere among
these unhealthy thoughts I had walked
too far and become overtired The Haven
if my cottage seemed suddenly desirable
and I forced my heavy feet to quicken
their lagging pace here now was the
Pinewood like a blot of India ink on the
lesser darkness at the night one hundred
yards within it lay the cottage but
despite my impatience they were the
slowest hundred yards i traversed that
night karen himself would have tripped
over something in the pitch blackness of
the wood nothing of the distant
flickering of the Lightning penetrated
here I had literally to feel my way
along the path then all of a sudden I
stopped in surprise my hand on the bowl
of a pine somewhere ahead of me
glimmered a faint patch of light green
light
as I watched it it moved back and forth
with a sort of dreadful deliberate
slowness then it Stood Still and as I
peered at it I discovered a black cross
as it were intersecting it abruptly the
light disappeared and left me with the
realization that the black cross had
been the silhouette of the center of the
cottage windows frame somebody or
something was in the cottage my heart
started going like a two-stroke engine
then the human habit of rationalizing
unaccountable things came to the fore it
had been a Firefly or a jack-o'-lantern
of marsh gas from the stagnant pond not
far beyond the cottage or again this was
the sort of weather that generated those
globes of ball lightning which sometimes
popped down chimneys and flowed around
inside rooms or maybe a [ __ ] was
searching either for a bed for the night
or for the money for one but with a
green light I waited awhile but there
was no return of the phenomenon I hoped
that whatever it was it had gone away
then I fumbled my way through the last
few yards to the door and let myself in
in the darkness within I lit a match and
by its feeble light surveyed the room
the words is anybody there
died in my mouth for it was manifest
that there was nobody I conveyed the
flame to the oil lamp and the room
became bright and cheerful the shelves
of books still in their original color
dust jackets gladden my eye as the sight
of them always did and the model galleon
the bass of marigolds the shining pewter
tankards were all familiar and
reassuring things nevertheless I poured
myself a scotch and soda before I
settled down in the armchair by the
tireless hearth to read over and polish
the thousands of words I had scribbled
that day in the midst of my immersion in
my own story of the burning of a
particularly malignant witch I suddenly
noticed that the Scout muscles at the
back of my head were taught and
contracted and that my hair must be
bristling and I felt in my mind what my
body must have been aware of for some
time that there was some creature behind
me and watching me with no friendly
regard
without seeming to divert my attention
from my manuscript I gazed up from under
my brows at the mirror hanging above the
fireplace
it showed the wall behind me empty save
for a framed watercolour of the devil's
punchbowl at Hindhead which was just as
it should be with a relaxing of
tenseness I returned to my work but only
for a few moments some words I had
written earlier in the story recurred to
me
vampires cast no reflection in mirrors a
little cold tremor passed over me then a
spasm of fear inspired anger at my
childish timidity good lord to give him
moment's credence to that Dracula
claptrap I swung round and positively
glared behind me there were no fearful
fiends treading close behind me there
was nothing that had not been there
before fool I addressed myself bitterly
and began to turn slowly back in route
as it were my eye flickered past a brass
warming pan hanging on the side wall and
then abruptly flicked back to it for I
had the impression of a dim and
shapeless sort of face staring from its
bright round surface I sat and regarded
it yes there was certainly the effect of
a face an immobile dead sort of face
like that of the man in the moon and
scarcely better defined I got up to
examine it and it faded as I approached
it and quite disappeared when I got my
nose within a yard of it leaving just
the empty surface of the pan yet when I
sat back again in my chair there it was
once more two round black holes of eyes
a beaky nose a twisted gash of a mouth
along the top of the sideboard on the
opposite side of the room - it was an
assemblage of objects of ornament and
utility prominent among them were two
ebony candlesticks top heavy things with
round bulbous sockets for the candles it
was plain to me that the eyes of the
face were simply the reflection of these
two black balls the nose a partial and
distorted reflection of a vase and the
mouth probably a dent in the pan which
caught and held a content of shadow at
this particular angle
I dismissed the matter and returned
again to my scribbled pages in a little
while I came to a passage that I judged
needed wholly rewriting and I stared
thoughtfully before me while I
endeavoured to cast it afresh in my mind
subconsciously at first and then with
the start of realization I became
cognizant that I was gazing straight at
another face it was in the carving of
one of the pillars of the fireplace from
the coils of raised stone ostensibly
representing climbing vines a demonic
little vissa djurgården me with sharp
slanting spiteful eyes a vulpine face
like that of a fox cornered and snarling
so alive and venomous did it seem that I
instinctively moved back a little with
confused ideas of defensive measures
that flight movement was enough to make
the illusion vanish for it was an
illusion another trick of light yet
thatwe experimented by changing my
attitude in my chair I could not get the
effect to repeat itself
indeed I even became uncertain of the
spot amid the intricacies of the
carvings were aided seemed to appear not
very surely I returned to my business
but it was a long while before I could
put those two faces from my mind I had
almost finished when that sickening
feeling of being watched came over me
again for a little while I dared not
raise my eyes from the papers that
trembled in my hands in my imagination
it seemed to be that I was surrounded by
a host of evil and silently threatening
faces that they leered and glowered not
only from the dark corners but also from
the bright surfaces of the things I had
thought so homely and reassuring when I
had come in from the outer darkness when
a sudden resolution to face them all and
be damned to them I looked up I caught a
fleeting impression of a huge face
filling the whole wall of the empty
alcove beside the fireplace but the
patches of discoloration from dampness
that had apparently formed it seemed
almost to shift apart in that instant
and become wholly innocent and of no
significance
I threw my papers down and jumped up
with an oath what is this I demanded of
myself am I going mad or is something
trying to drive me mad
I went determinately around the room
gazing straightly at all its contents in
turn but I saw nothing in the least out
of the ordinary then I stood in the
middle of the hearthrug and debated upon
my state of affairs firstly I had no
further inclination to do any more work
on my book tonight I had had enough of
pondering upon the Sinister secondly I
wished either that I had company or was
in some less lonely spot in the
countryside than I was but outside the
cottage was the wood and outside the
woods stretched the wide heath under the
night sky miles of black mystery between
me and the nearest glow of humanity
thirdly despite my days unusual mental
and physical effort I no longer felt
tired nor did the thought of bed lure me
I felt that if I did sleep now
bad dreams if nothing worse would come I
decided that I would write some letters
just a hold as I wrote them the mental
image of some of those exuberant friends
of mine in London from whom I had fled
would provide something of a sense of
company it would give me a link with
that pleasant world of every day from
which I was so utterly cut off in this
stifling electrically ominous night
the thought of letters caused me to
wonder whether any had been delivered in
the Evening Post while I had been out I
was already opening the little door of
the letter cage when it occurred to me
that I had deliberately withheld my
address from all but Spencer
nevertheless I groped irrationally in
the dark interior and felt a little
thrill of pleasure when my fingers
encountered a letter the only one I felt
something else to a mild shock which
made those fingers tingle a bit it was
almost as if the letter had contained an
electrical charge I put it down to the
atmosphere the letter was from Spencer
as I might have guessed it wasn't very
helpful looked at from any point of view
he was in his most cryptic mood it was a
neat typescript and began without any
preamble it was signed yours faithfully
by Spencer and that seemed to me almost
the only comprehensible part of it as
for the rest well here it is word for
word as I remember it Apple the composer
Robert Schumann long heard voices and
saw things that were not there he went
mad angle as did in like manner the
author of Gulliver's Travels
Jonathan Swift agram the poet Shelley
was tormented all his life with dreams
and visions once an awaking vision he
encountered a figure shrouded in a dark
cloak it was himself on another occasion
he heard a noise outside the country
cottage where he was staying he opened
the door and was struck unconscious by
something invisible Adyar on when young
John Bunyan had fearful dreams and
visions pestilent spirits and devils
appeared to him until he reached the age
of seventeen then they disappeared for
two years during which time he gave
himself up to every evil passion and led
a corrupt life in 1651 his visions came
again and he said that he was hounded by
the devil he swore that he sometimes
felt the tempter pull my clothes and
sometimes the devil took the form of a
bull bush or bezel all the demons in the
pilgrims progress came out of his
memories of these experiences alpha
William Blake the poet and artist had
dreams and visions all his life he left
a record of not only how he saw the
devil but also how he drew him he wrote
I was going downstairs in the dark when
suddenly a light came streaming at my
feet I turned around and there he was
looking fiercely at me through the iron
grating of my staircase window as he
appeared so I drew him Blake's sketch
showed a horrible phantom glaring
through a grated window with burning
eyes long teeth and claws like talons
William Blake went mad so my friend
remember while you were pent up in your
little cottage to beware of dreams and
visions
no decidedly not a cheering
communication I cursed the man for his
perverted sense of humor if this was
supposed to be humor and is maddening
obscurantism but it struck me as strange
that the arrival of such an effort as
this should coincide with a time at
which I was seeing things I sat down and
studied the typed sheet with a frown
Akal agram adder on what gibberish words
were these what connection was there
between them if I guess Spencer's
twisted mind right there was some link
quite possibly he had put a clue in the
wording he was always searching for some
such crazy but deliberate clues in the
writings of Shakespeare to indicate that
the plays were actually written by
Francis Bacon I went slowly through the
wordage again
why I pondered a capital P for pent wait
a moment pentacle pentagram I seized
upon a volume of my encyclopedia and
sought what I soon found this entry
pentacle Pentangle pentagram pentad Iran
or pentalpha these various names all
belong to the design of a five-pointed
star composed of five straight lines
which may be formed complete without
severance of the tracing medium from the
recording medium ie it may be drawn
without the pen being lifted from the
paper for the tip of the pen returns to
its starting point possibly for some
such oddity is this the sign has long
been used as a mystical symbol first by
the pythagorean's and later by the
astrologers and necromancer's of the
Middle Ages it is found frequently in
early ornamental art and is still
sometimes used in superstitious regions
of the world on doorways to keep away
witches and evil spirits
there followed representations at the
pentacle etc and the hexagram two
interlaced equilateral triangles with
which it is often confused while I had
the P volume in my hand I thought I
might as well look up Pythagoras of whom
I knew nothing except that he had been a
Greek philosopher with a theorem his
time it appeared was the sixth century
BC and he traveled around quite a lot
passing through Egypt among other places
and went to Italy in 529 BC and founded
their religious Brotherhood for the
Reformation of mankind through
practicing certain rites reaction
against him began in his lifetime and
reached a head in the middle of the
fifth century BC his movement was
violently trampled out meeting houses of
pythagorean's were everywhere sacked and
burned and pythagorean's persecuted and
slain well all that was fairly
interesting I suppose but I still didn't
see any point to the letter yet there
was still the coincidence of its arrival
and my fit of the willies I lay back in
my chair with half-closed eyes pondering
on the dreams and visions of the
illustrious people Spencer had listed I
was a writer of sorts an artist in my
own particular line I prided myself but
I had no illusions about my name living
any longer than I did a hundred years
hence no one would be the slightest bit
interested to learn that I had died in a
madhouse or had regular bouts of
delirium tremens for some time my mind
dwelt upon the ephemerality of the
second-rate writers little Fame and then
began to work in its usual way of
putting two ideas together and
fashioning from them something fresh the
slow shaping of a new story about a
brilliant writer who went mad at the
height of his fame went on in my
imagination I was lost in it
detachedly I became aware that the
illumination of the room appeared to be
slowly changing in its quality the
normal yellow a white light of the oil
lamp was taking on a faint tinge of
green I was still deep in abstraction
and paid little heed to it at first but
presently it became so pronounced that I
took an absent-minded look at the lamp
it was very low I remembered in a vague
sort of way that I had forgotten to get
any more paraffin
the greenish light was coming from
somewhere on my left where the window
was and I thought it was some queer
effect of the moonlight shining in I
glanced over at the window and my heart
gave a bound that I thought had
displaced it a sort of silent screaming
horror held me paralyzed the window was
a square of greenly translucent light as
though it were the side of an
artificially illuminated aquarium and
glaring threw it at me was William
Blake's nightmare vision of the devil
the eyes burned into mine the fangs were
revealed in a tiger's grin the whole
effect was that of a monster aflame with
sadistic appetite measuring its distance
for a pounce at my throat I'm afraid I
fainted it's a weakness no man likes to
admit to but it does happen it happened
to me and I'm very thankful that it did
when I came to the oil lamp was but a
mere glimmer reflected like a star in
the black opacity of the window before
me for there was no trace left of my
frightful visitant the night outside was
as dark as a cavern deep in the earth
and no shape of anything not even the
adjacent Pines could be discerned I got
up shaking like an ancient car and had
to lean on the table for a few moments
while I cured my knees if they're
curious tendency to give then in a
trembling but Swift manner
I became urgent with action first I
slammed home the bolts of the door I
didn't know why the thing hadn't come in
after me that way but I wasn't going to
give it the advantage of any second
thoughts then I pulled the thick curtain
over the window I was afraid to go near
the window to do this I might suddenly
find myself literally face to face with
the thing and I didn't think my heart
would stand it so I hooked the curtain
over with the end of a broomstick and I
was holding myself well away from the
other end of it
then I laid the poker on the table ready
for emergencies it was a comfortably
heavy length of iron and then I had a
couple of neat whiskies there was
nothing I could do about the lamp there
wasn't any more oil and I wasn't going
out to search for any at this time of
night the very thought of feeling about
among the unseen trees out there again
made me shudder
I found a stub of candle and lit it but
it wasn't going to last long so I built
a huge fire on that sultry summer night
I had a blaze going that near melted me
but I didn't mind feeling warm so long
as I could feel more secure and bright
firelight was a sight better than
absolute darkness i sat close by the
fire streaming with sweat my poker at
hand and I resolved not to let that
light fail nor myself sleep until dawn
and the Blessed daylight came my eye
fell on Spencer's letter on the table I
had enough of that sort of thing I
reached over and grabbed it and was
about to drop it into the fire when I
noticed for the first time a diagram
traced on the back of it it was a
pentagram executed with extremely neat
draftsmanship in very thin lines of what
appeared to be green ink as I studied it
it seemed to stand out from the paper as
though it were embossed and then the
paper appeared to fade away from around
it leaving the pentagram like a green
wireframe and the wire began to glow
until the center of my vision was
nothing but a blankness in which the
pentagram glowed like a green neon sign
which grew bigger and bigger the
friendly fire light was being blotted
out and now there were faces faces
grinning and leering faces pressing all
about me an increasing crowd and a green
light brightening and glowing over
everything
the last Wendling remnant of my will
just managed to snap the spell like
wrenching oneself out of the hypnosis of
a nightmare and in that snap the horrors
vanished and there I was sitting in the
firelight was just an ordinary piece of
paper in my hand but not for long and a
spasm of fear in rage I screwed it into
a ball and threw it into the heart of
the fire
there was a brief spurt of green flame
it might have been a pinch of some
chemical in one of the logs
I stayed awake all night but I was not
troubled further by visions in the
morning I packed my things and fled back
to London dear old dirty but safe
Bloomsbury with the shabby temple of the
British Museum and the little streets
full of foreign dining rooms and book
shops and the captive trees in the grimy
squares as soon as I had got resettled
in my apartment I marched round to
Mecklenburg Square to demand a Spencer
what the hell though callers for him
were few and far between
he had fitted a Yale lock to the door of
his big bed sitting-room at the top of
the gray house and he kept the door shut
and himself on the other side of it but
he had long trusted me with a key I got
no answer when I knocked so I let myself
in there was his desk in the far corner
littered with books and papers as usual
and there was his old-fashioned winged
armchair in which he spent more time
asleep than in his bed but there was no
sign of him of course he might be doing
some research in the museum reading room
on the other hand he might be out eating
in one of the neighboring cafes I
presumed he did eat sometimes though I
had never seen him at it but those were
the only reasons that I could imagine
would ever take him out of this room he
took no exercise and had no use for
fresh air how he managed to find the
oxygen to breathe in this place I could
never understand the door and window
were always shut I walked over to and
had a struggle with the window but it
was quite a moveable through years of
neglect window and frame had amalgamated
i sat myself in his armchair and
glancing idly about the room every
available wall space from floor to
ceiling was taken up with laden
bookshelves the famous library on the
Black Arts demonology spiritualism and
every aspect of the supernatural there
was his large double bed in the corner
unmade as always it's tangled clothes
draping down on the carpet
the stained old coffee pot stood on the
hearth and there were cigarette stubs
thrown anywhere about the floor
standing like a rock in the sea of
documents letters files clippings
pamphlets and allied paper matter which
flowed over the desk with Spencer's
typewriter there was a sheet of paper in
it half filled with typescript curious
to learn what Spencer was working on now
I got up and had a look at it I found it
was page four of a letter obviously
addressed to me so I looked on the desk
for the previous sheets and found them
as far as the letter went I read it with
absorption dear Bill I suppose when this
reaches you you will be cursing me for a
sleepless night probably you will have
found the immediate cause of it if not
this letter will enlighten you so that
you can destroy the said cause and sleep
the sleep of the innocent consider the
humble pentagram it's become a jolly
little figure of fun now good luck and
all that sort of thing you might get it
in the form of a lucky charm from a
Christmas cracker or see a dozen of it
representing stars and the illustrations
to children's fairy storybooks
businessmen who like playing at secret
societies which are also good for
business use it for a secret recognition
symbol between one member and another
they copied that trick from the
pythagorean's but the pythagorean's were
alive to the dread secret they shared in
which they kept from the ordinary people
yet even these Philosopher's
geometrician were a bit astray upon one
point because they trace manifestations
to the presence of a pentagram of a
certain size and shape they thought that
the secret lay in that certain size and
shape and certainly the same effects
were brought about through using exact
duplicates of that original pentagram
but the whole secret really lies in just
one triangle of that figure the surface
size is irrelevant and the rest of the
pentagram frame redundant
it's the angles of that one triangle
which are important fashioned a triangle
with its three angles of sizes I could
give you though an error amounting to a
second will suffice to make an impotent
and you will have a triangle of terror
indeed I'll tell you that one angle is
36 degrees 47 minutes 29 seconds if you
want to play games with trial and error
when you hit upon the right one and
leave it about you'll start seeing
things sooner or later but your chances
are small it is not an isosceles
triangle but a scalene the original
pentagram was a very rough effort far
from symmetrical and only by a fluke did
it contain this dangerous triangle how
did I discover all this it began with my
investigation of the haunting of a
cottage in Norfolk I connected the
phenomena with a small glass prism which
had been lying about the place the
former occupant was a spectroscopy until
he went mad and was put away on a couple
of occasions when the spooks were about
to appear I noticed that this prism took
on a Paley translucent quality of green
proceeding according to scientific
method I found that the cottage was not
haunted if the prism was taken away from
it but the vicinity of the prism was
wherever one took it I had a rather
unpleasant time discovering that I must
tell you about it sometime
unfortunately I dropped the prism one
day and broke a corner off and it was
never the same again it became just
another piece of glass but I had taken
exact measurements of it and I kept them
years later I traced by exhaustive trial
and error the cause of another haunting
in a residential house on Putney common
to the presence of of all things a paper
fastener a triangular one I took careful
measurements of this and compared them
with the dimensions of that remembered
prism I knew I had hit upon something
what I found that its angles though not
the area and closed by them correspond
adapt salutely exactly with the angles
of one of the naturally triangular ends
of the prism the end I had broken
I'm afraid I didn't keep my evidence
long I was so troubled by dreams and
visions as long as it was in my
possession that I was finally driven to
bending it out of shape that made it
harmless a simple little action like
that but I found plenty of confirmatory
evidence that haunted Riverside bungalow
at Teddington I removed and destroyed
one of those common triangular shelf
brackets and got the credit for
exercising the spirits do you know why
Berlin rectory is still known as the
most haunted house in Britain because I
couldn't get permission to attack a beam
completing a triangle out of one of the
Gables I tell you you've only got to
look around any of these haunted houses
and know what you're looking for and
you'll find the cause of the trouble
sooner or later it may be a fortuitous
triangle of scratches on the wall a coat
hanger or even the side of a pepper pot
but it's always there when I was making
researches into the history of the
pythagorean's I found the secret was
known to them centuries before the time
of Christ only they mistook the
pentagram for the cause and not just the
triangle contained therein they used to
practice the rites of raising these
unpleasant apparitions and then
conquering them by destroying the sign
they felt purified by the struggle with
evil and uplifted by the symbolic
victory over it I'm not sure though that
they always had the victory naturally
they kept these dark secrets from common
men but the people gradually got wind of
it feared and hated them as sorcerers
and tried to expunge them the
persecution reached its height in the
middle of the fifth century BC
everywhere the meeting houses if the
pythagorean's were burned down and any
pythagorean's found their slain you're
probably wondering why a particular kind
of triangle should cause such phenomena
anyway so am i I'm still investigating
my own theory at the moment goes like
this firstly these devils and demons
which appear have no material existence
and in fact no existence at all outside
your own mind they exist in our
unconscious mind memories we are born
with handed down for our most primitive
ancestors do you remember when you were
a child alone in your own bedroom trying
to sleep
those uneasy times when you imagined you
saw faces
nasty glare IED frightening faces in the
darkness of your room and when you shut
your eyes to escape them there they were
behind your eyelids clearer than ever
they're the things our terror dreams are
built upon children see them more than
we do for the imagination is so much
more active in childhood in adults it
gradually grows moribund and we become
creatures of habit but very sensitive
and imaginative people who live more in
their unconscious mind than their
conscious one the introverts still see
them very sensitive and imaginative
people I repeat like artists poets
composers like Blake Shelley Schumann
you begin to get the idea the music
makers and the dreamers of dreams far
more strongly than extroverted
materialistic people
I can't imagine those businessmen having
much trouble with their pentagrams even
if by a remote chance they hit upon a
Pythagorean one they react to this
touchstone of a triangle it acts as a
sort of gateway through which seep ever
more strongly the images and waves of
the unconscious until they flood over
and submerge the conscious mind
altogether and when that happens to a
man we say he is mad the conscious mind
weighs and judges it is our critical
faculty it keeps us in balanced relation
to the material world but when it is
gone we are helpless we will believe in
anything that our unconscious mind
believes in for that wholly possesses us
now why have it all great men like
Beethoven Shakespeare da Vinci gone mad
why only a small proportion I anticipate
your questions well simply because they
never happened to come into
juxtaposition with one of these
triangles but the ones I have listed and
many others that I have not must have
had that triangle somewhere about their
houses or quite conceivably within their
own physical body a bone structure or
vein formation are some such freak
effect
it seems that physical vision of the
triangle is not necessary extrasensory
perception is pretty firmly established
and I am inclined to believe that the
design is perceived extrasensory if it
is close at hand it seems to exert a
hypnotic effect on the subjects mind but
in just what manner is yet to be
discovered
what are thought waves anyway and may
not they react only against certain
designs as a certain design of antennae
is needed to catch television waves come
to that what is imagination it is
because you are a writer and therefore
have some amount of imagination that I
sent you my little puzzle and pentagram
it should have had some amusing results
however I don't think they will have
been harmful I had read your books and
assess the quality of your imagination
and I don't think you need fear the fate
of the writers I have mentioned after
all once you fully realize that these
phantoms only emerge from your own mind
it should the letter ended there in
mid-sentence which I thought a little
odd this was the first I had heard of
Spenser carrying out practical
investigation of hauntings any sort of
action seemed so unlike him had he been
called away to one now I wondered if
Spencer had judged the quality of my
imagination solely from my books he was
at fault I'm not nearly so
matter-of-fact as the style of those
books suggests that style is opposed to
cover up at almost morbid sensitivity I
may not be as highly strong as where any
of the writers Spencer had listed but I
certainly didn't think last night's
results amusing and I shouldn't have
liked to predict the outcome if I hadn't
destroyed the pentagram in time know
when Spencer returned he was going to
find that in me he had reaped a
whirlwind meanwhile I would give him
another half hour before I went and had
lunch
i sat down pondering upon the incredible
revelations of the letter yet from my
independent experience I could not doubt
the truth of them I wondered whether it
was possible to cure cases of madness
caused that way there was a chance of at
that moment I caught sight of something
that sent an electric shock through me
the sole of his shoe
just under Spencer's large bed partially
hidden by the carelessly flung
bedclothes and this soul was balancing
upright on its toe a position impossible
unless that shoe contained a human foot
there was somebody lying face downwards
under the bed
I had to force myself to go over and
investigate it was Spencer as I had
feared and he was dead he had forced
himself under the bed as far as his bulk
would allow and I had a strenuous time
getting him out there was a sort of
horrible ludicrousness about those
efforts but when I saw his face I didn't
think there was anything in the least
funny about it both mouth and eyes were
wide open something about the
countenance reminded me of the cast and
the Pompeii Museum of the poor
unfortunate who was suffocated in terror
beneath the ashes of the eruption which
buried his City and the irises of the
eyes were turned slightly in and upwards
like those of a man in an apoplectic fit
it was a ghastly effect
and I knew he had been seeking refuge in
a blinding animal fear from something
which had literally scared the life out
of him poor Spencer what an impossible
and ridiculous refuge he had flown to
what awful presence had unbalanced such
as scholarly mind broken such a firm
character made a tragic clown out of
such a mature and wise man of course
according to his own theory he would be
very susceptible to these frightening
visions from the unconscious because he
lived so largely in the recesses of his
own mind and was usually more than semi
oblivious to his surroundings in his
company
yes his own discovery must have
destroyed him and then I was struck by
an appalling realization this couldn't
have happened without the imminent
presence of that terrible triangle it
must still be somewhere about in all
probabilities somewhere in this room
if I weren't careful panic thoughts
chased about in my brain I attempted to
get a grip upon myself I stood up it was
quite obvious what I must do
I must go straightaway and inform the
police was that something moving over
there by the door whether it was or not
fear suddenly closed in upon my soul I
felt sick in the stomach and my whole
body began to tremble a secondary
reaction from last night's horror show
joined forces with the shocks of these
fresh discoveries images of the triangle
I feared kept trying to shape and my too
lively imagination I fought to keep it
out of my mind I must get out of here I
must get out of here
I was muttering to myself is a too
rather shaky step towards the door and
then stopped with an end Ron gasped as
though a bucket of very cold water had
been thrown over me between the door and
myself stood a tall
he had slightly hunched creature out of
the worst of my childhood nightmares a
mad drooling thing with a face rotten
with corruption with dead blink less
eyes that seemed to be gazing past me
and yet I knew that they were not in
reality the things whole attention was
upon me but it was not an intelligent
attention it was the unthinking
unreflecting but blindly eager attention
of the slavering and snuffling village
idiot who slowly and deliberately pulls
the legs off a spider or takes a knife
to a captive Sparrow and
works unimaginable cruelty z' upon it
and this thing was after me cold sweat
broke out upon me my conscious mind was
hammering away it isn't real it isn't
real it won't hurt you it's just your
own imagination you're becoming
hypnotized break the spell look away I
dragged my eyes from it and my gaze fell
full upon Spencer lying dead at my feet
on his back his queer eyes seeming to
strive to see his own forehead with a
sob I stumbled across him and gained the
fireplace I clung to the mantelshelf
still keeping my gaze averted from the
direction of the door the stained coffee
pot on the hearth was looking up at me
it had become a face with a grotesque
spout of a nose it was one of the
leering faces I had seen last night with
a quite uncalculated action like a
reflex kick I lifted it violently with
the toe of my shoe and it went smashing
into fragments against the farther wall
that was an unexpected relief in sudden
hope I dared a glance towards the door
but the slobbering staring thing was as
real and as potentially murderous as
ever it had advanced considerably
towards me and now I could see details
of it that I wished I could not it's
dead white hands were reaching out ready
to clutch and grip it seemed inexorably
sure of itself and adding to my terror
it moved with absolute soundless Nassif
it breezed I could not hear it it
approached me like an image from an old
silent film a moving shadow it is a
shadow said one part of my mind only a
shadow that you're throwing and another
voice was shouting the window escaped by
the window and another voice was saying
the window is jammed you can't open it
my mind was a roaring confusion of
divided impulses all overridden by the
dominating rush of fear I knew that it
was disintegrating that my conscious
mind was going to pieces under the
strain and when that salivating horror
got me I should go screaming mad as
others had gone mad
I made one last desperate effort to
clear a space in that chaos in which to
think connectedly the triangle this was
all happening through the medium of the
triangle I must find it there was not a
moment to lose I must destroy it quick
where what could it be
was it a bracket of that pipe rack I
tore it down and smashed it but without
looking I knew that I was still pursued
God there were a thousand things in this
room that might contain it I went
through a brief fury of breaking every
suspicious thing I could lay my hands
upon within my limited radius but still
I was forced to retreat until I was
pressing against the desk in the far
corner from the door and shaking like a
paralytic I could retreat no further I
think I was beginning to scream
voiceless ly as I scrambled in mad
desperation among the books and papers
on the desk my eyes literally bulging
with anxiety and there baffled search
for something triangular in one
convulsive sweep I shot a whole heap of
the clutter from the desk it revealed
the blotting pad that pile had covered
in the center of the blotting pad was a
familiar outline in green ink the
pentagram I knew it was what I saw it I
pounced on it like a wild animal and
ripped it across and ripped again then I
turned around weakly with the pieces in
my hand the thing which had almost had
its fingers on my throat was gone I
began to chuckle feebly and kept tearing
the blotting pad across and across again
tossing the small pieces in the air they
fluttered to the floor like a miniature
stage snowstorm like Wellington after
Waterloo I kept saying to myself a near
run thing a near run thing and all
because of the fact that when old
Spencer had drawn so carefully that
representation of the pentagram he sent
me he had blotted it on his pad and
never noticed that he had left a perfect
reproduction of those dangerous angles
among his papers that was his undoing I
suppose he was frightened to death the
doctor diagnosed coronary thrombosis and
the coroner saw fit to agree with him
sometimes these days I catch myself
trying to agree with him too it is human
to rationalize but I do know that I am
never under any conditions going to play
about with any triangles that include
one angle of 36 degrees 47 minutes and
29 seconds
in fact I am allergic to triangles of
any kind
[Music]
when Carson first noticed the sounds in
his cellar he ascribed them to the rats
later he began to hear the tales which
were whispered by the superstitious
polish mill workers in Derby Street
regarding the first occupant of the
ancient house Abigail Prynne there was
none living today who could remember the
diabolical old hag
but the morbid legends which thrive in
the witch district of Salem like rank
weeds on a neglected grave gave
disturbing particulars of her activities
and were unpleasantly explicit regarding
the detestable sacrifices she was known
to have made to a worm-eaten Crescent
horned image of dubious origin the
oldsters still muttered of Abbey Prynne
and her monstrous boasts that she was
High Priestess of a fearfully potent God
which dwelt deep in the hills indeed it
was the old witches reckless boasting
which had led to her abrupt and
mysterious death in 1692
about the time of the famous hangings on
gallows Hill no one liked to talk about
it but occasionally a toothless crone
would mumble fearfully that the flames
could not burn her for her whole body
had taken on the peculiar anaesthesia of
her which mark Abbe Prynne and her
anomalous statue had long since vanished
but it was still difficult to find
tenants for her decrepit gabled house
with its overhanging second-story and
curious diamond paint casement windows
the houses evil notoriety had spread
throughout Salem nothing had actually
happened there of recent years which
might give rise to the inexplicable
tales but those who rented the house had
a habit of moving out hastily generally
with vague and unsatisfactory
explanations connected with the rats and
it was a rat which led Carson to the
witch room the squealing and muffled
pattering within the rotting walls had
disturbed Carson more than once during
the nights of his first week in the
house which he had rented to obtain the
solitude that would enable him to
complete a novel for which his
publishers had been asking another light
romance to add to Carson's long string
of popular successes but it was not
until sometime later that he began to
entertain certain wildly fantastic
surmises regarding the intelligence of
the rat that scurried from under his
feet in the dark hallway one evening the
house had been wired for electricity but
the bulb in the hall was small and gave
a dim light the rat was a misshapen
black shadow as it darted a few feet
away and paused apparently watching him
at another time Carson might have
dismissed the animal with a threatening
gesture and returned to his work but the
traffic on Derby Street had been
unusually noisy and he had found it
difficult to concentrate upon his novel
his nerves for no apparent reason were
taught and somehow it seemed that the
rat watching just beyond his reach was
eyeing him with sardonic amusement
smiling at the conceit he took a few
steps toward the rat and it rushed away
to the cellar door which he saw with
surprise was ajar he must have neglected
to close it the last time he had been in
the cellar although he generally took
care to keep the door shut for the
ancient house was drafty the rat waited
in the doorway unreasonably annoyed
Carson hurried forward sending the rats
scurrying down the stairway he switched
on the cellar light and observed the rat
in a corner it watched him keenly out of
glittering little eyes as he descended
the stairs he could not help feeling
that he was acting like a fool but his
work had been tiring and subconsciously
he welcomed any interruption he moved
across the cellar to the rat seeing with
astonishment that the creature remained
unmoving staring at him a strange
feeling of uneasiness began to grow
within him the rat was acting abnormally
he felt and the unwinking gaze of its
cold shoe button eyes was somehow
disturbing then he laughed to himself
for the rat had suddenly whisked aside
and disappeared into a little hole in
the cellar wall idly he scratched across
with his toe in the dirt before the
Burrow
deciding that he would set a trap there
in the morning the rats snout and ragged
whiskers protruded cautiously
it moved forward and then hesitated drew
back then the animal began to act in a
singular and unaccountable manner almost
as though it were dancing Carson thought
it moved tentatively forward retreated
again it would give a little dart
forward and be brought up short then
leap back hastily as though the simile
flashed in to Carson's mind a snake were
coiled before the Burrow
alert to prevent the rats escape but
there was nothing there save the little
cross Carson had scratched in the dust
no doubt it was Carson himself who
blocked the rats escape for he was
standing within a few feet of the Burrow
he moved forward and the animal
hurriedly retreated out of sight his
interest piqued Carson found a stick and
poked it exploring Lee into the hole as
he did so his eye close to the wall
detected something strange about the
stone slab just above the rat burrow a
quick glance around its edge confirmed
his suspicions the slab was apparently
moveable Carson examined it closely
noticed a depression on its edge which
would afford a handhold his fingers fit
it easily into the groove and he pulled
tentatively
the stone moved a trifle and stopped he
pulled harder and with a sprinkling of
dry earth the slab swung away from the
wall as though on hinges a black
rectangle shoulder-high gaped in the
wall from its depths a musty unpleasant
stench of dead air welled out and
involuntarily carson retreated a step
suddenly he remembered the monstrous
tales of abbey Prynne and the hideous
secrets she was supposed to have kept
hidden in her house had he stumbled upon
some hidden retreat at the long dead
witch before entering the dark gap he
took the precaution of obtaining a
flashlight from upstairs then he
cautiously bent his head and stepped
into the narrow evil-smelling passage
sending the flashlights beam probing out
before him he was in a narrow tunnel
scarcely higher than his head and walled
and paved with stone slabs it ran
straight ahead for perhaps fifteen feet
and then broadened out into a roomy
chamber as Carson stepped into the
underground room no doubt a hidden
retreat of Abbey Prince a hiding place
he thought which nevertheless could not
save her on the day the freight crazed
mob had come raging along Derby Street
he caught his breath in a gasp of
amazement the room was fantastic
astonishing it was the floor which held
Carson's gaze the dull Brae of the
circular wall gave place here to a
mosaic of very colored stone in which
blues and greens and purples
predominated indeed there were none of
the warmer colors there must have been
thousands of bits of coloured stone
making up that pattern for none was
larger than a walnut and the mosaic
seemed to follow some definite pattern
unfamiliar to Carson there were curves
of purple and violet mingled with angled
lines of green and blue intertwining in
fantastic arabesques there were circles
triangles a pentagram and other less
familiar figures most of the lines and
figures radiated from a definite point
the centre of the chamber where there
was a circular disk of dead black stone
perhaps two feet in diameter
it was very silent the sounds of the
cars that occasionally went passed
overhead and Derby Street could not be
heard in a shallow alcove in the wall
Carson caught a glimpse of markings on
the walls and he moved slowly in that
direction the beam of his light
traveling up and down the walls of the
niche the marks whatever they were had
been dogged upon the stone long ago for
what was left of the cryptic symbols was
indecipherable Carson saw several partly
effaced hieroglyphics which reminded him
of Arabic but he could not be sure on
the floor of the alcove was a corroded
metal disk about eight feet in diameter
and Carson received the distinct
impression that it was moveable but
there seemed no way to lift it he became
conscious that he was standing in the
exact center of the chamber in the
circle of black stone where the odd
design centered again he noticed the
utter silence on an impulse he clicked
off the ray of his flashlight instantly
he was in dead blackness at that moment
a curious idea entered his mind he
pictured himself at the bottom of a pit
and from above a flood was descending
pouring down the shaft to engulf him so
strong was this impression that he
actually fancied he could hear a muffled
thundering the roar of the cataract then
oddly shaken he clicked on the light
glanced around swiftly the drumming of
course was the pounding of his blood
made audible in the complete silence a
familiar phenomenon but if the place was
so still the thought leaped into his
mind as though suddenly thrust into his
consciousness this would be an ideal
place to work he could have the place
wired for electricity have a table and
chair brought down use an electric fan
if necessary although the musty odor he
had first noticed seemed to have
disappeared completely he moved to the
tunnel mouth and as he stepped from the
room he felt an inexplicable relaxation
of his muscles although he had not
realised that they had been contracted
he ascribed it to nervousness and went
upstairs to brew black coffee and write
to his landlord in Boston about his
discovery
the visitors stared curiously about the
hallway after Carson had opened the door
nodding to himself as though with
satisfaction he was a lean tall figure
of a man with thick steel gray eyebrows
overhanging keen gray eyes his face
although strongly marked and gaunt was
unwrinkled about the which room I
suppose Carson said ungraciously his
landlord had talked and for the last
week he had been unwillingly
entertaining Antiquaries in occultus
anxious to glimpse the secret chamber in
which a beep Rin had mumbled her spells
Carson's annoyance had grown and he had
considered moving to a quieter place but
his inherent stubbornness had made him
stay on determined to finish his novel
in spite of interruptions now eyeing his
guests coldly he said I'm sorry but it's
not an exhibition any more the other
looked startled but almost immediately a
gleam of comprehension came into his
eyes he extracted a card and offered it
to Carson Michael Lee a cultist day
Carson repeated he drew a deep breath
the occultists he had found were the
worst with their dark hints of nameless
things and their profound interest in
the mosaic pattern on the floor of the
witch room I'm sorry mr. Lee but I'm
really quite busy you'll excuse me
ungraciously he turned back to the door
just a moment
Lee said swiftly before Carson could
protest he had caught the writer by the
shoulders and was peering closely into
his eyes startled Carson drew back but
not before he had seen an extraordinary
expression of mingled apprehension and
satisfaction appear on Lee's gaunt face
it was as though the occultist had seen
something unpleasant but not unexpected
what's the idea Carson asked harshly I'm
not accustomed I'm very sorry
Lise said his voice was deep and
pleasant I must apologize
I thought well again I apologize I'm
rather excited I'm afraid you see I've
come from San Francisco to see this
which room of yours would you really
mind letting me see it I should be glad
to pay any sum Carson made a depper
Kotori gesture no he said feeling of
perverse liking for this man growing
within him his well modulated pleasant
voice his powerful face his magnetic
personality no I merely want a little
peace you have no idea how I've been
bothered he went on vaguely surprised to
find himself speaking apologetically
it's a frightful nuisance I almost wish
I'd never found the room Lee leaned
forward anxiously may I see it it means
a great deal to me
I'm vitally interested in these things I
promise not to take up more than ten
minutes of your time
Carson hesitated then assented as he led
his guests into the cellar he found
himself telling the circumstances of his
discovery of the which room Lee listened
intently occasionally interrupting with
questions the rat did you see what
became of it he asked Carson looked
bemused why no I suppose it hidden its
burrow why one never knows Lee said
cryptically as they came into the which
room
Carson switched on the light he had had
an electrical extension installed and
there were a few chairs in a table but
otherwise the chamber was unchanged
Carson watched the occultist face and
with surprise saw it becoming grim
almost angry Lee strode to the center of
the room staring at the chair that stood
on the black circle of stone you work
here
he asked slowly yes it's quiet I found I
couldn't work upstairs too noisy but
this is ideal somehow I find it very
easy to write here my mind feels he
hesitated free that is disassociated
with other things it's quite an unusual
feeling Lee nodded as though Carson's
words had confirmed some idea in his own
mind
he turned toward the alcove in the metal
discs in the floor
Carson followed him the occultist moved
close to the wall tracing out the faded
symbols with a long forefinger he
muttered something under his breath
words that sounded like gibberish to
Carson me otaku jana he swung about his
face grim and pale i've seen enough
he said softly shall we go surprised
Carson nodded and led the way back into
the cellar
upstairs Lee hesitated as though finding
it difficult to broach the subject at
length he asked mr. Carson would you
mind telling me if you've had any
peculiar dreams lately Carson stared at
him mirth dancing in his eyes dreams he
repeated oh I see well mr. Lee I may as
well tell you that you can't frighten me
your compatriots the other occultists
I've entertained have already tried it
Lee raised his thick eyebrows yes did
they ask you whether you dreamed several
did yes and you told them no then as Lee
leaned back in his chair a puzzled
expression on his face Carson went on
slowly although really I'm not quite
sure you mean I think I have a vague
impression that I have dreamed lately
but I can't be sure I can't remember
anything of the dream you see and
ovarian occultist put the idea into my
mind perhaps Lee said noncommittally
getting up he hesitated mr. Carson I'm
gonna ask you a rather presumptuous
question is it necessary for you to live
in this house Carson sighed resignedly
when I was first asked that question I
explained that I wanted a quiet place to
work on a novel and that any quiet place
would do but it isn't easy to find them
now that I have this which room and I'm
turning out my work so easily I see no
reason why I should move and perhaps
upset my program I'll vacate this house
when I finish my novel and then you
occultist can come in and turn it into a
museum or do whatever you want with it I
don't care
but until the novel is finished I intend
to stay here Li rubbed his chin indeed I
can't understand your point of view but
is there no other place in the house
where you can work
he watched person's face for a moment
and then went on swiftly I don't expect
you to believe me
your materialist most people are but
there are a few of us who know that
above and beyond what men call science
there is a greater science that is built
on laws and principles which to the
average man would be almost
incomprehensible
if you've read maken you will remember
that he speaks of the gulf between the
world of consciousness and the world of
matter it is possible to bridge that
gulf the which room is such a bridge do
you know what a Whispering Gallery is a
person said staring but there's no an
analogy merely an analogy a man may
whisper a word in a gallery or a cave
and if you're standing in a certain spot
a hundred feet away you will hear that
whisper although someone ten feet away
will not it's a simple trick of
acoustics bringing the sound to a focal
point and this principle can be applied
to other things besides sound to any
wave impulse even to thought Carson
tried to interrupt but Lee kept on that
black stone in the center of your which
room is one of those focal points the
design on the floor when you sit on the
black circle there you are abnormally
sensitive to certain vibrations certain
thought commands dangerously sensitive
why do you suppose your mind is so clear
when you're working there a deception a
false feeling of lucidity for you are
merely an instrument a microphone tuned
to pick up certain malign vibrations the
nature of which you could not comprehend
Carson's face was a study in amazement
and incredulity but you don't mean you
actually believed Lee drew back the
intensity fading from his eyes leaving
them grim and cold very well but I have
studied the history of your Abigail
Prynne she too understood the
super-science of which I speak she used
it for evil purposes the black art as it
is called I've read that she cursed
Salem in the old days and a witch's
curse can be a frightful thing
you he got up knowing in his lip will
you at least allow me to call on you
tomorrow almost involuntarily Carson
nodded but I'm afraid you'll be wasting
your time I don't believe I mean I have
no he stumbled at a loss for words
I merely wished to assure myself that
you know another thing if you dream
tonight will you try to remember the
dream if you attempt to recapture it
immediately after waking it is often
possible to recall it all right if I
dream that night Carson dreamed he awoke
just before dawn with his heart racing
furiously
and a curious feeling of uneasiness
within the walls and from below he could
hear the furtive scurrying zuv the rats
he got out of bed hastily shivering in
the cold grayness of early morning a wan
moon still shone faintly in a paling sky
then he remembered Lee's words he had
dreamed there was no question of that
but the content of his dream that was
another matter he absolutely could not
recall it to his mind much as he tried
although there was a very vague
impression of running frantically in
darkness he dressed quickly and because
the stillness of early morning in the
old house got on his nerves he went out
to buy a newspaper it was too early for
shops to be open however and in search
of a newsboy he set off westward turning
at the first corner and as he walked a
curious and inexplicable feeling began
to take possession of him a feeling of
familiarity he had walked here before
and there was a dim and disturbing
familiarity about the shapes of the
houses the outline of the roofs but and
this was the fantastic part of it to his
knowledge he had never been on this
street before he had spent little time
walking about this region of Salem for
he was indolent by nature yet there was
this extraordinary feeling of
remembrance and it grew more vivid as he
went on he reached a corner turned
unthinkingly to the left the odd
sensation increased he walked on slowly
pondering no doubt he had traveled by
this way before and very probably he had
done so in a moody daydream so that he
had not been conscious of his route
undoubtedly that was the explanation
yet as Carson turned into charter Street
he felt the nameless unease waking
within him Salem was rousing was
daylight impassive polish workers began
to hurry past him toward the mills an
occasional automobile went by before him
a crowd was gathered on the sidewalk
he hastened his steps conscious of a
feeling of impending calamity with an
extraordinary sense of shock he saw that
he was passing the Chartres Street
burying ground the ancient evilly famous
burying point hastily he pushed his way
into the crowd comments and a muffled
undertone came to Carson's ears and a
bulky blue-clad back loomed up before
him he peered over the policeman's
shoulder and caught his breath in a
horrified gasp a man leaned against the
iron railing that fenced the old
graveyard he wore a cheap gaudy suit and
he gripped the rusty bars and a clutch
that made his muscles stand out in
ridges on the hairy backs of his hands
he was dead and on his face staring up
at the sky at a crazy angle was frozen
an expression of abysmal and utterly
shocking horror his eyes all whites were
bulging hideously his mouth was a
twisted merciless grin a man at Carson's
side turned a white face toward him
looks as if he was scared to death
he said somewhat hoarsely I'd hate to
have seen what he saw look at that face
mechanically Carson backed away feeling
an icy breath of nameless things chill
him he rubbed his hands across his eyes
but still that contorted dead face swam
and his vision he began to retrace his
steps shaken and trembling a little
involuntarily his glance moved to side
rested on the tombs and monuments that
dotted the old graveyard no one had been
buried there for over a century and the
Lycan stained tombstones with their
winget skulls fat cheek cherubs and
funeral urns seemed to breathe out an
indefinable miasma of antiquity what had
frightened the man to death Carson drew
a deep breath true the corpse had been a
frightful spectacle but he must not
allow it to upset his nerves he
not his novel would suffer besides he
argued grimly to himself the affair was
obvious enough in its explanation the
dead man was apparently a pole one of
the group of immigrants who dwell about
Salem Harbor passing by the graveyard at
night a spot about which eldritch
legends had clung for nearly three
centuries his drink befuddled eyes must
have given reality to the hazy phantoms
of a superstitious mind these poles were
notoriously unstable emotionally prone
to mob hysteria and wild imaginings the
great immigrant panic of 1853 in which
three which houses had been burned to
the ground had grown from an old woman's
confused and hysterical statement that
she had seen a mysterious white clad
foreigner take off his face what else
could be expected of such people Carson
thought nevertheless he remained in a
nervous state and did not return home
until nearly noon when on his arrival he
found Lee the occultist waiting he was
glad to see the man and invited him in
with cordiality Lee was very serious did
you hear about your friend Abigail
Prynne he asked without preamble and
Carson stared pausing in the act of
siphoning charged water into a glass
after a long moment he pressed the lever
sent the liquid sizzling and foaming
into the whisky he handed Lee the drink
and took one himself neat before
answering the question I don't know what
you're talking about has what's she been
up to he asked with an air of forced
levity I've been checking up the records
Lee said and I find Abigail Prynne was
buried on December 14th 1690 in the
charter street burying ground with a
stake through her heart what's the
matter nothing Carson said tonelessly
well well her graves been opened and
robbed
that's all the stake was found a brood
nearby and there were footprints all
around the grave shoe prints did you
dream last night Carson lease snapped
out the question his gray eyes hard I
don't know Carson said confusedly
rubbing his forehead I can't remember I
was at the Chartres Street graveyard
this morning
oh then you must have heard something
about the man who I saw him person
interrupted shuddering it upset me he
down the whiskey at a gulp Lee watched
him well he said presently are you still
determined to stay in this house person
put down the glass and stood up why not
he snapped is there any reason why I
shouldn't after what happened last night
Lee said after what happened a grave was
robbed a superstitious pole saw the
robbers and died of fright well you're
trying to convince yourself Lee said
calmly in your heart you know you must
know the truth you become a tool in the
hands of tremendous terrible forces
Carson for three centuries Abbey print
is lain in her grave undead waiting for
someone to fall into her trap the witch
room perhaps she foresaw the future when
she built it foresaw that someday
someone would blunder into that hellish
chamber and be caught by the trap of the
mosaic pattern it caught you Carson and
enabled that undead horror to bridge the
gulf between consciousness and matter to
get in rapport with you hypnotism is
child's play to a being with Abigail
Prince frightful powers she could very
easily force you to go to her grave and
uproot the stakes that held her captive
and then erase the memory of that act
from your mind so that you could not
remember it even as a dream Carson was
on his feet his eyes burning with a
strange light in God's name man do you
know what you're saying
Lee laughed harshly God's name the
devil's name rather the devil that
menaces Salem at this moment for Salem
is in danger terrible danger the men and
women and children of the town Abbey
printer swen they bound her to the stake
and found they couldn't burn her I've
been going through certain secret
archives this morning and I've come to
ask you for the last time to leave this
house are you through Carson asked
coldly very well I shall stay here
you're either insane or drunk but you
can't impress me with your poppycock
would you leave if I offered you a
thousand dollars
Lee asked or more than ten thousand I
have a considerable sum at my command no
damn it
Carson snap in a sudden blaze of anger
all I want is to be left alone to finish
my novel
I can't work anywhere else
I don't want to I won't I expected this
li said his voice suddenly quiet and
with a strange note of sympathy man you
can't get away you're caught in the trap
and it's too late for you to extricate
yourself so long as a bee Prinze brain
controls you through the which room and
the worst part of it is that she can
only manifest herself with your aid she
drains your life-forces carson feeds on
you like a vampire
you're mad Carson said dully I'm afraid
that iron disc in the which room I'm
afraid of that and what's under it
Abbie Prince served strange gods Carson
and I read something on the wall of that
alcove that gave me a hint have you ever
heard of Nyanza Carson shook his head
impatiently Lee fumbled in a pocket drew
out a scrap of paper I copied this from
a book in the Kester library he said a
book called the Necronomicon written by
a man who dealt so deeply into forbidden
secrets that men called him mad
read this Carson's brows drew together
as he read the excerpt men know him as
the dweller in darkness that brother of
the old ones called Niang feh the thing
that should not be he can be summoned to
Earth's surface through certain secret
caverns and fissures and sorcerers have
seen him in Syria and below the black
tower of leg from the Fang grotto of
tartar II he has come ravening to bring
terror and destruction among the
pavilions of the Great Khan only by the
looped cross by the vac Faraj
incantation and by the takuna lick sir
may he be driven back to the knighted
caverns of hidden foul nough swear he
dwelleth
liebe at Carson's puzzled gaze calmly do
you understand now incantations and
elixirs Carson said handing back the
paper fiddlesticks far from it
that incantation and that elixir have
been known to a cultists and adepts for
thousands of years I've had occasion to
use them myself in the past on certain
occasions and if I'm right about this
thing he turned to the door his lips
compressed in a bloodless line such
manifestations have been defeated before
but the difficulty lies in obtaining the
elixir it's very hard to get but I hope
I'll be back can you stay out of the
witch room until then I'll promise
nothing Carson said he had a dull
headache which had been steadily growing
until it obtrude it upon his
consciousness and he felt vaguely
nauseated goodbye
he saw Lee to the door and waited on the
steps with an odd reluctance to return
to the house as he watched the tall
occultist hurry down the street a woman
came out of the adjoining house she
caught sight of him and her huge breasts
heaved she burst into a shrill angry
tirade Carson turned staring at her with
astonished eyes his head throbbed
painfully the woman was approaching
shaking a fat fist threatening Lee why
you scare my Sara she cried her swarthy
face flushed why you scare her with your
full tricks
Carson moistened his lips I'm sorry he
said slowly very sorry I didn't frighten
your Sara I haven't been home all day
what frightened her the brown thing it
ran in your house Sara said the woman
paused and her jaw dropped her eyes
widened
she made a peculiar sign with a right
hand pointing her index and little
fingers at Carson all her thumb was
crossed over the other fingers the old
witch she retreated hastily muttering in
polish in a frightened voice Carson
turned went back into the house he
poured some whiskey into a tumbler
considered and then set it aside on
tasted he began to pace the floor
occasionally rubbing his forehead with
fingers that felt dry and hot
vague confused thoughts raced through
his mind his head was throbbing and
feverish at length he went down to the
which room he remained there although he
did not work for his headache was not so
oppressive in the dead quiet of the
underground chamber after a time he
slept how long he slumbered he did not
know he dreamed of Salem and have a
dimly glimpsed gelatinous black thing
that hurtled with frightful speed
through the streets a thing like an
incredibly huge jet-black amoeba that
pursued and engulfed men and women who
shrieked and fled vainly he dreamed of a
skull face peering into his own a
withered and shrunken countenance in
which only the eyes seemed alive and
they shone with a hellish and evil light
he awoke at last sat up with a start he
was very cold it was utterly silent in
the light of the electric bulb the green
and purple mosaic seemed to writhe and
contract toward him an illusion which
disappeared as his sleep fogged vision
cleared he glanced at his wristwatch it
was two o'clock he had slept through the
afternoon and the better part of the
night he felt oddly weak and a lassitude
held him motionless in his chair the
strength seemed to have been drained
from him the piercing cold seemed to
strike through to his brain
but his headache was gone his mind was
very clear
expectant as though waiting for
something to happen a movement nearby
caught his eye a slab of stone in the
wall was moving he heard a gentle
grating sound and slowly a black cavity
widened from a narrow rectangle to a
square there was something crouching
there in the shadow stark blind horror
struck through Carson as the thing moved
and crept forward into the light it
looked like a mummy for an intolerable
age long second the thought pounded
frightfully at Carson's brain it looked
like a mummy it was a skeleton thin
parchment Brown corpse and it looked
like a skeleton with the hide of some
great lizards stretched over its bones
it stirred it crept forward and it's
long nails scratched audibly against the
stone it crawled out into the which room
it's passionless face pitilessly
revealed in the white light and its eyes
were gleaming with charnel life he could
see the serrated ridge of its Brown
shrunken back Karson sat motionless
abysmal horror had robbed him of the
power to move he seemed to be caught in
the fetters of dream paralysis in which
the brain and aloof spectator is unable
or unwilling to transmit the nerve
impulses to the muscles he told himself
frantically that he was dreaming that he
would presently awaken the withered
horror arose it stood upright skeleton
thin and moved to the alcove where the
iron disc lay embedded in the floor
standing with its back to Carsen it
paused and a dry and sere whisper
rustled out in the dead stillness at the
sound Carson would have screamed but he
could not still the dreadful whisper
went on in a language Carson knew was
not of Earth and as though in response
an almost imperceptible quiver shook the
iron disc it quivered and began to rise
very slowly and as if in triumph the
shriveled horror lifted its pipestem
arms the disk was nearly a foot thick
but presently as it continued to rise
above the level of the floor and
insidious odor began to penetrate the
room it was vaguely reptilian musky and
nauseating the disk lifted inexorably
and a little finger of blackness crept
out from beneath its edge abruptly
Carson remembered his dream of a
gelatinous black creature that hurtled
through the Salem streets he tried
vainly to break the fetters of paralysis
that held him motionless the chamber was
darkening and a black vertigo was
creeping up to engulf him the room
seemed to rock still the iron disk
lifted still the withered horror stood
with its skeleton arms raised and
blasphemous benediction still the
blackness used out and slowed amoeboid
movement there came a sound breaking
through the seer whisper of the mummy
the quick patter of racing footsteps
out of the corner of his eye Carson saw
a man come racing into the witch room it
was the occultist lee and his eyes were
blazing in a face of deathly pallor he
flung himself past Carson to the alcove
or the black horror was surging into
view the withered thing turned with
dreadful slowness Lee carried some
implement in his left hand Carson saw a
crux ansata of gold and ivory his right
hand was clenched at his side his voice
rolled out sonorous and commanding there
were little beads of perspiration on his
white face the fantastic unearthly
syllables thundered out echoing from the
walls of the vault Lee advanced slowly
the crux ansata held high and from
beneath the iron disc black horror came
surging the disc was lifted flung aside
and a great wave of iridescent blackness
neither liquid nor solid a frightful
gelatinous mass came pouring straight
for Lee without pausing in his advance
he made a quick gesture with his right
hand and a little glass tube hurtled
that the black thing was engulfed the
formless horror paused it hesitated with
a dreadful air of indecision and then
swiftly drew back a choking stench of
burning corruption began to pervade the
air and Carson saw great pieces of the
black fang flake off shriveling as
though destroyed with corroding acid it
fled back in a lick was entrusted his
black flesh dropping as it retreated a
pseudo pod of blackness elongated itself
from the central mass and like a great
tentacle clutched the corpse like being
dragged it back to the pit and over the
brink another tentacle seized the iron
disc pulled it effortlessly across the
floor and as the horror sank from sight
the disk fell into place with a
thunderous crash the room swung in wide
circles about Carson and a frightful
nausea clutched him he made a tremendous
effort to get to his feet and then the
light faded swiftly and was gone
darkness took him Carson's novel was
never finished he burned it but
continued to write although none of his
later work was ever published his
publishers shook their heads and
wondered why such a brilliant writer a
popular fiction had suddenly become
infatuated with the weird and ghastly
it's powerful stuff one man told Carson
as he handed back his novel black god of
madness it's remarkable in its way but
it's morbid and horrible nobody would
read it person why don't you write the
type of novel you used to do the kind
that made you famous it was then that
Carson broke his vow never to speak of
the which room and he poured out the
entire story hoping for understanding
and belief but as he finished his heart
sank as he saw the others face
sympathetic but skeptical you dreamed it
didn't you the man asked and Carson
laughed bitterly yes I dreamed it it
must have made a terribly vivid
impression on your mind some dreams do
but you'll forget about it in time he
predicted and Carson nodded and because
he knew that he would only be arousing
doubts of his sanity he did not mention
the thing that was burned indelibly on
his brain the horror he had seen in the
witch room after wakening from his faint
before he and Lee had hurried white face
and trembling from the chamber Carson
had cast a quick glance behind him the
shriveled and corroded patches that he
had seen slough off from that being of
insane blasphemy had unaccountably
disappeared although they had left black
stains upon the stones Abbie Prynne
perhaps had returned to the hell she had
served and her inhuman God had withdrawn
to hidden abysus beyond man's
comprehension routed by powerful forces
of Elder magic
the occultist had commanded but the
witch had left the momento behind her a
hideous thing which Carson in that last
backward glance had seen protruding from
the edge of the iron disk as though
raised in ironic salute a withered
claw-like hand